after we last spoke james in what april
2015 i think that's right it's been a
while yeah the world was probably a
not completely different place but it
was definitely different yeah
different um but when we spoke to you
then
did you have a vision of where you
wanted your filmmaking
career to go i think that if you
have an idea of where you need to go you
have to think about how you want to get
there
and so it's about steps and so when i
saw you last i had just done a couple of
projects
some of which i was happy with some of
which i wasn't and so i said
if i'm going to go where i want to be
eventually
i've got to be very specific with the
choices that i make
to get to that point and and that's what
i've been doing i've been very
meticulous
about the choices i've made and the
projects i've selected
the things that i've made i've ensured
that they have the resources requisite
to do
them and i've tried to be
at that point where i've had enough
experience that i know what i'm doing
but if i want to be where i want to end
up i've got to be very specific with
those choices i make
are you now where you wanted to be it's
interesting isn't it because you
when you're working i think that you
assume
that the mountain you're climbing is
the place you're going to end up right
if i make it to that point or if i make
that project that will get me here but
that's actually
false because when you get to the top
when you get to whatever
mountain you're trying to climb doesn't
matter what it is um
you realize there's a whole mountain
chain in front of you right
and you get there and like oh there's
now this next thing i have to
and this next thing i have to do and it
goes on and on
and so there really isn't a point in
which i think
uh you have arrived in that sense
there's always a new challenge or a new
uh
mountain that you have to climb and so
the further you climb
the more you get to do wherever
you're trying to get to you can get
closer to that was there anything that
happened and you don't have to give us
total specifics or naming names but
where it was like a real eye opener
that you weren't expecting it could be
positive negative certainly
um well when you're directing things uh
you don't always have
control over the outputs um you know
you're responsible for the creative
you're responsible for how it comes out
and if you've done a good or a bad job
or a mediocre or whatever it is
that comes out and creative but when
you're done with the film
you know it's the producers it's the
financiers they're the people that
dictate
uh what happens to that project and
that's something that can be very
disheartening to learn if it doesn't go
the way you hope it does
even if you've made a good film and
that's something you have to learn to
reckon with
uh that's one lesson that i have learned
for sure
since our last interview in 2015
it looks like you've turned your
attention to uh narrative shorts and
documentaries
features i have uh i going back to what
uh you were you were saying someone
asked me this
actually yesterday they're like so
you're doing documentaries and i was
like no not at all i just happen to be
doing
two documentaries right now um i
am in the middle of directing a film
about lucia lucas the first
transgender opera singer in american
history to have a title role
in uh in opera she plays don giovanni
and mozart's don giovanni
at the tulsa opera this earlier this may
um and we got to profile that experience
that entire journey which was wild you
know there's a new york times profile
there's a bbc profile there's an all
things considered piece coming out i
mean it's been a
fascinating journey to go through that
process and learn about opera
live simultaneously been directing a
film about american value systems and
how they're constructed over the past
two and a half three years that we will
finish shooting
this july and both of those films will
be out in 2020
so i'm in a really interesting position
where those two things are happening at
the same time
that doesn't mean i'm suddenly doing
documentaries it just happens to be what
i'm doing
at the moment i love documentary films
do not get me wrong
but i also love narrative films and so
going back to what i said
earlier um you make choices based on
what resources you have available
and so there's a couple of featured
narrative films that i'm doing
that are in different stages of
development but i'm not going to shoot
those films until i have the things that
i need
to get them done and that's why i've
done projects like angel of anywhere
which came out last year and did quite
well actually
they're narrative shorts that uh keep me
working in the interim
well you've done at least one short
documentary before on cancer
yes right i had done a few things about
cancer i also did a film called digital
edition about the atlanta drill
constitution's transition from
print to digital which i believe it in
and then i went to go be a filmmaker on
hillary clinton's campaign in the fall
and so it was a really interesting year
so like i've had a lot of very
interesting experiences since we last
spoke but back to what i
said i've been very specific about those
choices
and so for me to go between narrative
films documentaries
that's why i want to continue doing
because even some of the filmmakers that
i respect the most like jonathan demi
sydney lemay
the list goes on they did that
throughout their careers and i would
like to emulate that and so
that's what i'm trying to do just on a
side note and maybe you can't answer
this but
if you can't we'll stop of course um are
you able to tell me just what that was
like
working on the camera's campaign yeah i
can talk about that um
working on the campaign was unlike
anything i'd ever done but it also
an you know accumulation of all of my
experiences in some ways
i was in charge of the state of virginia
so i did advertising there
got to work with a variety of
influencers like miley cyrus
bellamy young sean astin uh the list
goes on and on
there were so many people uh and then
there were also private citizens
and then politicians like tim kaine
madeleine albright it was really a
wonderful experience to get to work with
all those people and create pieces with
them
so i'm sorry you were doing sort of
directing i was directing and shooting
and so i was i was a one-man
band in that sense so i directed shot
interviewed
packaged and and then worked with
brooklyn to distribute
those pieces so it was really a great uh
experience until the last day
yes so i'm just wondering if you could
take me through that like so you
have already planned or someone else has
already planned to have those people
come to a certain location or vice versa
right and so the way the campaign worked
is that uh
i would be told that you know here's a
list of people that are coming or i
might find out the day before this
person's coming to an event
somewhere in the state uh i would have
to figure out uh sort of like you figure
out with me what questions i need to ask
them
and how i would put them in a context so
uh for example uh with um
with uh madeleine albright yeah vladimir
i was trying to think of
what a good thing is and so madeleine
albright obviously we talked about
women's issues and women's rights and
and
and things like that when i had sean
aston
uh we took him to this uh little place
that was kind of urban in richmond
and we just kind of found things and and
places
that would emulate an issue or a topic
and and then place those subjects in
those environments which was really
quite
fun uh because i got to use all of my
skills in directing because i worked
with actors i worked with
politicians i worked with regular old
people so one of the reasons they
engaged me for that was
that i brought my film experience but i
also brought my documentary
experience and so it really was working
with both of those things to create
those advertisements for the campaign
very cool that sounds like it was really
awesome it was really it was intense it
was very intense
uh and not much sleep but you know you
don't sleep much in film anyway
sure but i mean and that's really a once
in a lifetime it was a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity during
the campaign
and so the reason i wanted to do that
was you know i i personally liked
hillary and i've liked her a long time
but i also
uh i also thought was historic
opportunity once a lifetime opportunity
i don't see myself doing something like
that ever again
because i have no desire to suddenly
start doing political advertising or
you know film and politics i want to
keep making narrative films and
documentaries
but i thought that was an opportunity
that was too interesting to say no to
and that's sometimes what you gotta do
you sometimes say yes and do it and
it's just something i've done now so
last question about this and then i'll
wrap up but when you
saw the email or whatever that you could
have this opportunity
how long did it take you to make the
decision say yes what was a big decision
because i had to decide if i wanted to
uproot my life for a few months and go
to the other side of the country
uh it's not like uh just directing a
film for a month or two on location
you're embedded for months
in a totally different environment now
mind you they provided me with housing
and you know all the stuff that you do
some people sometimes think i was
volunteering on that no they were paying
me for my services
but um but they provide all those things
and so it took me a couple of days to
decide but
i knew pretty quickly that
why would you say no to that it's such a
unique opportunity
you know once your
run with the hillary clinton campaign
was done how much time went by before
you decided you were going to jump into
this other
right well i was pretty depressed
it was that rough for about six months
it was pretty personal
and i uh about a month
went by i'm back home here in los
angeles and
i got a an email from a producer that i
know
and she said there is this guy named guy
who lives in israel who grew up in the
united states
who is interested in making a film about
american values systems and because you
had worked on the campaign and because
you you know have a
diverse film background i thought about
you immediately and thought that you
could be
a good fit to chat about his concept for
a film and
essentially guy said that he had been
doing a live
reading about american value systems and
how they're created
how our daily choices in life and how
they're expressed in elections
are directly correlated with the value
systems
uh that we identify as being american
which is a really broad topic right and
so that was the first thing i said i was
like
i agree with you but i don't know if one
makes a 90-minute film about that
because
it's such a broad topic and so we
started talking and we realized that
you could start sorting those into
tangible examples through issues like
immigration
technology and isolation
and other things and then we started uh
figuring out how to make it and we did
our first shoot
at the end of 2016 two weeks before the
inauguration in 2017.
and we've been shooting across the
country ever since and we're going to
finish shooting it
in july and august of this year 2019
to release it before the election in
2020.
it's not a political film even though
politics is an element it's
neither liberal nor conservative which
might be surprising to someone
considering i worked on hillary's
campaign
but growing up in a small town in south
georgia you know i see the world in this
very specific way where i can
see how to understand
how many people come to many different
thought processes just from
from life experience and so if we pull
it off
i think it's going to be a good film to
really
explain how we as a society
create our identity and how that's
informed by a long line of history
uh from civilizations that came before
america
interesting and are you doing it by by
like to intend your increments to since
things have changed well that's a good
question uh but it's really about a
snapshot
of now uh and then we're putting that in
context of of other civilizations that
have risen and fallen effectively
using a myrad of tangential subjects in
the northeast
a bunch of academic and and journalistic
experts
from from major organizations uh across
the country
and we'll be putting those things
together and it's not that we're
reinventing a wheel here there's a lot
of this information that's out there but
it's in different books or different
pieces and really what we're trying to
do is take all of those
elements and combine them together into
a singular
place where you can have a better
understanding about how things work
and i'm sorry guy is a guy's i'm sorry i
didn't expect
no that's a guy guy is a a political
consultant an academic an entrepreneur
he lives in israel he does a mixture of
all those things
and so uh he's worked on campaigns he's
created companies he's done a lot in
a variety of spaces he's never done a
film before
and so that has been a you know
interesting process to go through
uh with a group of people that don't
really work in film and kind of bring
them into a
filmic process and uh try to take
something from academia and put it in
something that's digestible for a main
audience
so guys in israel yeah
like we have phone calls international
phone calls at weird hours he does come
to america we go back and he goes back
and forth between here and there
when we did our first assembly at it
last year with carlos
puga who was the producer of a true life
on mtv he's also had
uh several films at sundance and south
by that won jury awards
he did the edit with us and we're using
that edit to
inform what we're about to shoot this
summer so that way we can use that to
finish the film and so
guy has been going back and forth
between here and there so it's always
interesting when you're working with
people on multiple time zones around the
world
and you say you you want to have it as
sort of a general statement you're not
for one side or the other
certainly and so i mean that's uh you
know i think philosophically as a
director it doesn't matter if you're
making a narrative film or a documentary
i think that in fact doing both makes
the effort better in fact
uh as far as your work goes uh but your
job
is to get inside the mind of a character
right so if it's a documentary it's
understanding how
that person has become the person they
are
and what that a to b is when you're
directing a narrative film
it's understanding the same psychology
of character
and so i find that using those processes
and and trying to figure out how to
how to make something that is
broad-based it doesn't matter what your
personal opinion is about a character or
a subject you have to divorce yourself
from that
it matters that you understand how they
got there and that's really to my mind
one of the first jobs of the director
creatively
what do you do when a film angers you
when you're just totally outraged oh
when you're
outraged when you're outraged with the
film well i certainly have strong
opinions why i'm watching characters or
subjects in a film i don't like them
right
but it's not my job as a director to
make a judgment call about a character i
think
i think it's my job to express them as
they are
fairly and so if i don't agree
with a character i don't like a
character right
i have to figure out how to
let the audience understand how that
person
got to that point or that character
whatever it is
i have to provide them with the
psychosis
so they can make that decision for
themselves
i might be trying to project something
obviously every director is trying to
project
something with the film right but i
think my job is more about
creating an overall pashmina this kind
of bigger
fabric of theme and within that theme
how do those characters
tie into that and that is my job
to to make sure the theme is coming
together as expressed through those
characters as long as i'm being
fair with the characters so that way you
as an audience member can make a
decision whether or not to like that
person or not
what if you're not the director for the
film you're an audience member
whether it's narrative documentary and
it just totally angers you
there aren't many films i get really
angry with but when i do get angry with
it i think it's
i think that there's nothing wrong with
being angry at a character
or being angry with a film or a subject
about anything really i think that a
more passionate response probably means
that
you made a more interesting film uh i
think there's nothing wrong with passion
uh for example mother last year i think
was last year
or the year before one of the two but
when mother came out
i personally loved it i laughed my head
off the whole time i thought it was the
funniest film i had seen that year
but no one else in the theater felt that
way i was the only one people were
leaving
walking out and even saying that film
out loud on this world is it so many
youtube
comments that i'm reading that is gonna
spark debate and and i think that
is indicative of an interesting film you
can decide if it's good or bad
but i think that if it's something that
lingers with you if you get angry if it
sparks a
reaction that means you've done
something interesting
how has your preparation evolved i think
in some ways my
preparation has evolved in the sense
that i want to have
a stronger idea of
what i think the overarching theme is
going to be
um i think sometimes when we're
prepping for films especially when
you're first starting out you're really
engaged in plot and character and you
should be i'm not saying
don't be engaged in plot or character
but i think in some ways you need to be
more engaged in
theme because the more you understand
what the big themes are the better
you're able to work with
character and plot to make those themes
extrapolate
and it's everything from production
design to cinematography to editing
choices
color everything across the board
informs
theme and so if you can walk into a film
and say this is the palette that i want
to paint
then all those other things if you've
done all the prep work right if you have
a good script if you have a good story
whatever it may be
you'll find that they come into focus
much quicker
james the town you grew up in has like
what 123 people
i i flip the sign every time i go back
yes
so when you come and go do you do you
cross off the three i said i i tell that
man it's a joke it's a bad joke
anyway so you you said off camera that
you've been back and forth several times
um
when you go back do you have sort of
this broader view of like this is the
town i grew up in
i remember the stories that i wanted to
tell and now
i have the chance to do that or or or is
it of course
no i i think about that constantly
actually
um i mean i'm very lucky uh they're not
uh there are many filmmakers that are
way more talented than me that are
not nearly as lucky as i have been i i
go
home and and i love going home
it's so much different environmentally
that is being in los angeles or
even shooting somewhere around the world
you know coming home is home no matter
where
you're from and when i go there i kind
of look around
i see people that i grew up with i see
you know
people that have been big influences in
my life people that have died
and i think about the life that i
could have had uh versus the life i have
now
um and that's not to say that life would
have been bad i want to be clear it
would have been different
um but it still would have been a good
life living in belleville or anywhere in
that region there are many wonderful
people that live there
um but i've been really lucky to work
with some of the
the top town in the world and and to do
it all over the world and
and not many kids from belleville
georgia or towns that small get that
opportunity and
i think for me having that perspective
every time i go home
it just reminds me how lucky i've been
and and i'm really grateful
do you think it's all luck though
because it sounds like you plan things
for sure i mean they're not everything's
luck
um i think that it does require
planning and methodology but
as someone told me not long ago you can
be making the best music in your
living room if nobody hears that music
it doesn't matter right
so there is a bit of luck you have to
meet the right people you have to be in
the right places
and it's true that talent is not the
only thing
that makes a career successful as i said
there are many talented filmmakers i
know that have not been as lucky as i
have been or that
don't work in film anymore because they
weren't very lucky
i just happened to meet some of the
right people at the right time in my
career who have been very helpful to me
because i was in the room at the right
time there is an element of luck
and i think the discount that uh
is not truthful you've really got to
have a mixture of talent and stamina and
vision but also a little bit of luck
uh because if you're doing that work in
your living room and nobody knows or
editing that film and nobody sees it
who cares any tips on
to filmmakers on how to get luckier
because yeah how do you get luckier go
to every film festival and meet
everybody that's there
that you get into i i think that i in
particular
figured out a very early age and i'm
glad i learned that lesson that i needed
to start going to film festivals
uh and then networking at those
festivals not making my
an idiot of myself hopefully making a
good impression
and the thing that's remarkable now that
i'm almost 31
i've been doing this since i was 19 18.
um and so there are festivals in this
country that i have been going to since
i was 19
and i still go to those festivals in
fact
one in georgia the macon film festival
that was the first festival to program
my work
one of the coolest things happened over
the past few years i directed a film
called
angel of anywhere that's a film about a
empathetic
stripper who plays therapist at his bar
it's a drama at a strip club
and we won best narrative short there i
had never won
award at the macon film festival since
19 years old never not once not an
audience award
nothing but they had programmed every
film of mine
since then and so it was the i mean
i teared up i still do a little bit just
it was it was kind of emotional for me
because it was
it doesn't seem like it's a big thing
but when you have that kind of a
relationship that history
uh you kind of look back on your work
and you can see that arc and
it's just been remarkable to go to
festivals like macon and others across
the country not just
there um and see the same audience come
back
every year because you're there for the
film because it's your film because they
know you and
and they know you work and and over time
that's what builds an audience because
you're building your little tribes all
over the country and uh
it's kind of neat to look back on that
it really is
and even 10 years from now what that
will look like you know
i am very cognizant of how lucky i've
been in my career
um i think for me it's it's felt more
acutely because of where i grew up
because i grew up in this tiny small
town south georgia
um i i feel that i feel that there are
many talented filmmakers out there that
have not been as lucky as i have been um
and then they're made they've been much
luckier than i have been too so you know
i certainly
do not see myself in that way but i
think people forget
that progress and that jury you have to
go on there are a lot of people that say
they want to do film
but they don't really know what that
looks like
it's long hard days
long hard hours the part that's
glamorous that people perceive to be
glamorous
is such a tip of the iceberg thing
that it's not really why
you should do it if that's what you
think
it is you shouldn't be doing film uh
it is 18 20 hour days sometimes
it is days like i'm in now because i am
having to direct two films at the same
time and throw an ad campaign in the
middle of it
i am working from i don't believe in
mornings as a rule unless i'm filming
but i am working from like 10 in the
morning
to sometimes three or four at night on
an edit
on a film with my team to get it done on
time because i have another film i'm
directing because i have another ad
campaign i'm directing because i'm
having to figure out
how to have my schedule in los angeles
mesh with going to singapore and being
in the northeast and being in israel
and then manage those things all at the
same time
all at the same time that's not
glamorous
that's hard damn work and and
if you aren't ready to do things like
that
and i understand that i'm lucky and that
is not common even my own life that is
not common this is an unusual time
but if you aren't prepared for that to
be a possibility
when you cross that bridge and hopefully
you will
you got to be ready for it and to do
that it takes a lot of sacrifice
and yeah i'm young i mean only 31 now
i'm 31
a month but i've been doing this for
like almost
15 years it's a long time and
i certainly haven't been a place where i
would say i've made it
but i think that if i've been able to do
this non-stop as my only job for 15
years
pretty damn lucky it's interesting when
someone is
young how maybe there are more
detractors in that sense just because
people think
well that's not fair but you're not
taking someone else's chance
sure but i took that i knew what i
wanted to do early on and then i did it
um and then i was lucky enough to meet
the right people and go to the right
places to build a network that enabled
me to do it
um because i've never had a full-time
job in my life
i've never worked at a starbucks i've
never driven an uber
so far um i've been very lucky
that this is all i do if i'm not
directing a film or a documentary i'm
directing an ad or a music video or some
company wants me to do a you know a
corporate piece or whatever it is
i've been lucky and i've figured out how
to make that work
um but i also knew what i wanted to do
and i did it
and so i think that if you want to do it
or if you're like well how do you
get to that point you got to be ready to
put in the hours
can you take us through the process of
narrative film versus documentary what
are the differences
in shooting feature films of either of
those two well the differences between
doing a documentary or narrative
in the sense that you have to tell a
story isn't any different right the the
difference is that
in a documentary you have a concept
right it's like here's a one sentence
log line about the film that i
think i'm going to make usually by the
end of that filming period the film you
thought you were making is usually much
different than the film you made
i also find that can sometimes be the
same in narrative films
because you go in with one idea about
here's what's on the page but when you
bring in performers who have their own
ideas and thoughts
i believe again philosophically as a
director if you're going to engage
actors or a dp or anyone you really
should permit them to use the skills
that they're trained in and so they're
going to have ideas and thoughts
that will change the general idea and
trajectory of
the film but those are similarities the
difference is
in a documentary is that you've got to
assemble the story
as you're going and so it's not that i'm
working from a script and saying oh what
do i need to cut out or we're running
out of time or
do we need to rework this maybe the
dialogue isn't working
a documentary it's being cognizant of
tracking your story as you're shooting
it to say this is the log line i
started with and now it's tracking
towards something different
if that difference is a better film
how do i get from here to here because
you're doing it
in real time and so if you're successful
and you come out on the other end with a
good film because you've tracked it and
you figured it out
i think it makes your narrative
storytelling much better because a
you have a better idea of human behavior
and how people
do things how things are constructed but
b
you go through this deconstruction of
story in real time that you don't have
to go through when you're shooting a
narrative film that's something that you
would typically do in script development
right
but it enables you to do that
development much better because then you
can poke holes and structure of story
that i
think that might be a little harder if
you didn't have documentary experience
yeah having spoken with a few
documentary filmmakers on
how they go in to shoot one story and
then
it's different drastically some major
things happen
and then they're like okay do we make
the same film right do we
stop do you know and and have it i think
it's wiser to
to follow the story where it goes
sometimes you know it goes in unexpected
directions
uh even the film i just directed uh
about lucia lucas the opera singer
in tulsa oklahoma at the tulsa opera uh
she
uh you know i walked in with one log
line that she's the first transgender
opera singer in american history i have
a leading role
but as i'm shooting it was very apparent
to me even walking into it that you
can't make that be your film
that's the reason you're there but
that's not necessarily
the film those are two very different
things and so as i'm shooting i had to
follow the story and uh open up to other
characters and figure out how they all
interact together what pieces of a
puzzle
you need to kind of create a total
picture of how an opera is put together
how it's performed and delivered on the
backdrop of an international news story
that's also in tulsa oklahoma a very
unlikely place
so you're triangulating in that sense
all of these different elements to
create
the narrative and so if you do your job
right i think as a documentarian your
job is to apply those narrative film
skills to your documentary but as a
documentary filmmaker you're
a nimble enough to follow that story
wherever it goes
were you thinking of of how to approach
it during the flight to tulsa
or once you got there and entered the
world well i had lots of conversations
before i got there uh
yeah the that film came together very
quickly the producers
uh emailed me about a month before it
was supposed to be filmed and they said
here's the log
line are you interested and i was
fascinated immediately and i called them
and i
said you know i know nothing about opera
i've never been to an opera in my life
so i don't
i mean i love this story i think it's an
interesting could be interesting
but i don't know if i should do this and
they said we actually think because
you've
never been to an opera because you know
nothing about opera that you actually
might be the perfect person
because you'd look at it in a different
way and so
once they gave me permission to to be
okay with that
uh i started thinking more about what i
thought the story should be
and you know i had skype calls with
lucia who lives in germany
uh and then uh you know a couple of
those in advance
to try to get a better sense of who she
was what makes her tick
things like that and then
as i'm getting to tulsa and as i had
this kind of
base of knowledge that was structured in
a way where they're
you know doing an opera in 30 days right
so it's a very
you know straightforward structure it's
going from point a to point b
so i'm not having to invent that right
it's a kind of behind the scenes
uh film in that sense uh but
as you're filming you realize that there
are elements that you need to include
that you wouldn't have necessarily
picked up just from lucia or just from
the
the opera itself things about the town
things about the opera company
things about the nature of being a
performer these are all things that you
kind of
have to follow as you're filming to be
cognizant of to be aware of
so you know what the best version of the
film is that you're you're capable of
making
and there are opera groupies yeah and
they run the gamut
right and it's really fascinating i mean
learning about opera i mean i'll go to
the opera now it was really a
fascinating experience and
i still don't fully i understand
mechanically
what it means to project
and sing i don't know how how they do it
um i mean watching them
if you ever get the opportunity to make
a film with professional musicians from
all over the world
do that film it's a great experience the
the director of the show is from the
royal opera in london the artistic
director's tobias picker one of the most
prolific living
opera composers today he did adaptation
of roald dahl's fantastic mr
fox he's doing an adaptation of the
danish girl the conductors from uruguay
lucia's from germany i mean it was a
cast of people from all over the world
with different sensibilities but
all of them with world-class literally
talent
uh they're some of the top people in
that profession and
it was really cool it's really really
cool
one of the things they always talk about
in film or with acting whatever is just
kind of like when it rains it pours
and when it dries up it dries up so it
sounds like you've had a quite
rainy season in terms of i've had a lot
of work
rainy season which is great uh how are
you balancing it droughts aren't fun
and so i much prefer rainy season i
would prefer it to be
a little more sprinkly than thunderstorm
season but
but it's been great i was
i'm in the middle of directing the
american question my documentary about
american value systems and we had
planned to finish
shooting that this uh summer spring
summer because
uh we think it needs to be out before
the 2020 election just for marketing
reasons for
personal reasons a lot of reasons and
when i was getting ready to do that
shoot
i got a phone call from the producers of
the lucio lucas film and they asked me
if i wanted to come to oklahoma for a
month
in april this is somewhere around first
or second week of march
and so once they decide that they want
me to direct this film i had to totally
reconfigure my schedule for the summer
to prep for that film in march
to go to oklahoma in
april come back here to la in may for
the first assembly edit
i have a ad campaign in singapore next
month that i have to go do
and i'm coming back to finish shooting
the american question in july
which will be in the northeast and in
israel
while also running post-production
on lucia's film because both of those
films have
to be delivered for a 2020 release and
so it's a lot of juggling and time
management
and mind you even in march when i'm
having negotiations on
lucia's project i was working on three
other films at the same time
that were nothing to do with those two
other projects
and so i'm having to get those things
done while i'm also
doing negotiations planning and
realigning
the other film this is not typical this
is not my daily life
it's the first time i've dealt with
having to do two films at once
it's a wonderful problem to have i'm
glad i have this problem because i've
been in that drought before
no good uh but you just have to really
understand how to manage your time
and make sure everyone you're working
with feels like
they are getting adequate attention um
the second that they don't feel that the
more complicated your life becomes
in in what way uh in the way that they
don't think that you can do it
i mean it's really about confidence they
they have to understand
that you are focused on the project you
have been engaged for
and so even if i am working on three or
four things at the same time
even now i'm working on two or three
feature narrative films that
um one of two of which are getting quite
close
probably one we'll shoot next year um
i still have to make sure things are
happening on that and so it's
making sure that everything
has the resources they need to
to get going what needs to get done
right
and and also making sure that the people
working on them
know that you're focused on it they
don't necessarily have to know that
you're working on those five
other things uh they just need to know
they're working on
theirs you know any tips on how to
balance your time because it is
interesting how you could go through a
drought with whatever
and then all of a sudden all these great
things will happen at once and in some
ways it's like no i wanted to spread it
out and enjoy
this and this and this but i can't tell
you yeah
um i i think that especially when
i'm in an interesting place in my career
because i i'm
neither mated i guess but i'm not
starting out i'm in that weird
middle space where i have lots of work i
live comfortably
i've done a lot of the hard work to get
where i'm at but i haven't done you know
the avengers 20 and so and so i think
that when you're in that space you don't
have the luxury of saying no because
you're trying to get to that other space
not that i want to do the avengers 20
but if i do
great but you've got to
say yes to the things that you know you
can do well
to the things that you know are going to
help you
to the projects that make sense to you
creatively if you can juggle
and you can do all those things
effectively and do good work
that only helps you ascend the broader
mountain chain you're trying to climb
and also gives you better skill sets
because when you
can manage lots of different moving
pieces the bigger your films become
the higher your budgets get the more
depth you are at being able to do that
was it shonda rhimes who talked about
saying yes to everything for a year
maybe i'm getting it
yeah she said as the year of yes and
then chanda also has this uh
this uh you know crazy schedule with how
she
you know delivers edits on multiple
television shows and the way that she
works i've read a good bit about it i
don't know her personally
um and i think that you know that
there's a way to do that she she's right
like you have to say yes to all these
things but then you also have
to learn to manage and what makes sense
for you what makes sense for your
personal life making sure that
you have what you need because if you're
not satisfied creatively
or if you don't have uh
you know if you're so exhausted that you
can't manage it
it's probably not going to be good work
and so you've got to find a balance
but as long as you can balance all those
things or if you have the power
like i fortunately did to kind of have
some say over your schedule
uh you can make things work and so we'll
see how it comes out
you guys can find out what a few months
to be content yes
that's an interesting problem to be
sitting with right
now in the middle there and knowing that
you have to say yes because it's not
maybe you feel like it's not time to
turn stuff down right you're not at the
point where
like okay who's yeah tell so and so you
know you've got this assistant that's
you've got 20 people coming in handlers
on the stuff but at the same time
you're not starting out so i was
wondering did you ever envision
being in this place where you're
wrestling with that dilemma no you don't
i don't think you ever envisioned that
space
uh it's a space that i think is
something that happens with time right
it's it's one of those things when
you're first starting out you're like if
i can just get that first feature done
everything's fine
uh but that's not true right it's it's
then about proving that you're not a
one-trick pony
and so it's that middle space that maybe
is the most critical
because then you have to show a couple
of things one you have to show you've
got it you've got the stamina to keep
going that you're dedicated that you're
committed that this is what you're going
to do
but then you have to put out good work
and so as long as you're doing
consistent
good work in that middle space i believe
that is what helps you to get to that
next space but it really
is about saying yes to the things that
make sense it's not saying yes to
everything let's be very clear there are
things i turn down
all the time but if it's something that
makes sense to me creatively
if it has a budget on which i know i can
make a good film
if it has the right talent involved it
has people that i want to work with
then i'll do it i will figure out how to
do it
but i mean i say no to things that if i
don't care for
some of the entities involved or if i
think there's no way to make it on the
budget that they
want to do it on i'll say no to that
because that's not helpful
um and so i think that if you're looking
at your career in this broader way
you have to say yes to those things that
make sense
say no to the things that don't yeah
that that is another interesting thing
in that
taking a job that could actually hurt
you down the line because
maybe you did everything you were
supposed to but right
for whatever reason that other party
didn't
got a different playing buddy they have
a different they're playing by different
rules
or they don't know what they're doing or
you just don't like the way they work or
maybe you have
opposite processes of working which is
okay
it's all right if there is no one
way to do a film or to have a creative
process
i think that sometimes people and
especially in interviews like this
perceive that you know somebody like me
is saying this is the only way
to do this thing that's not true right
that's false
i read the youtube comments that's false
i don't think that um
you're not the only one to get there
there is no one way
there is no one way to do something
there's the way that i know how to do it
sure and and so you know even expressing
how
i do it is how i do it and so then it's
finding other people who share congruent
or similar
processes to
[Music]
collaborate with and then you tend to
have a more fluid process
but if you find that there's someone
that has
something that is so opposite or that
person
so odious or toxic or you know whatever
it may be
i can now at this point have the luxury
of choosing to say
no which is something i may not have had
six eight years ago
you know now i have that luxury and so
that's the weird middle right
you have enough experience where people
come to you with projects and say here
it is here's the budget
great you go do it um but
that doesn't mean you always want to say
yes and it's about self-preservation too
because if you say
yes to someone that you're not on the
same page and then there's a fiasco for
whatever reason
you have no control over and then it's
the longevity thing because if something
is a fiasco in the middle
this middle space i don't think you
can't afford to have many fiascos you
might be able to afford to have one
i don't know if you can afford many you
have to have as many things as close to
perfect or as best you can make it as
possible
it's i think that informative i think
it's that formative uh
that's the space because then if you
make one good film and then you make two
or three bad ones
then one trick pony if you make one or
two good ones three good ones one's off
like it's an off day but you can't
afford to make
bed work you've got to make sure that
you're making the best work that you can
make if you want to continue proceeding
especially in that middle ground
what are the biggest mistakes you've
made on the first day of shooting
i think some of the biggest mistakes
i've
made on the first day of shooting
usually pertain to interpersonal
things um at this point i
kind of know what i need to do to get
something done technically i know the
story
i know all of the different pieces that
i need to deploy to hopefully have a
good film and the first day obviously
sets the tone
for many of those things right you have
sometimes people you've worked with
hundreds of times and then sometimes
you've got people that are brand new
that you've never
seen before and so when you're doing
that i think you have to
figure out how those
relationships that you have existing are
going to mesh with those that are
new and so it's figuring out the
interpersonal dynamics of how these
people tick
what makes them tick deciding what they
think is funny or not funny
things like that because that tone you
set
on your set on the first day it does not
matter what the film is it can be
anything you're shooting an ad a
documentary
film whatever that is going to set the
tone with that person that doesn't know
you
for the rest of the shoot and if you
blow that
and i have before by misjudging someone
and and kind of what they you know how
they feel about things whatever it may
be
um it's then gotta be work on you to get
that back
to get them back uh and so i think that
that may be
for me personally the most uh
that's something i've messed up before i
try to do better about now
well and that's big of you to to admit
that you misjudged
but there are also people that look for
challenge
and they see someone in charge or
whatever
and whatever they're dealing with and
they're like no
i'm going to be the the thorn in the
side for this one
and some people definitely have that um
i try to
meet as many people as possible across
as many departments as possible before
shooting something to kind of get a
sense of people and how they are
and if there's someone that i think is
so egregious i'll talk to a department
head and say let's cut this person i've
done it
um and and so you know that
tone and and tone and climate in a
in a set to me is very important and it
starts at the top it starts with me
if you set a good tone if you set a good
atmosphere for your cast for your crew
typically even if you are working on a
lower budget
or if someone's not being paid as well
whatever it is
um they will work better
because they like the space they're in
and so it is on me as director to set
that tone if
i'm heinous or if i come in with a bad
attitude
that trickles down very fast and so it's
really my job to
figure out what makes my crew and my
cast tick
and once i understand the dynamics of
that then i have a lot more latitude to
do the things that i want
yeah i don't know if i would really see
you being the one
i'll just say that but but i'm sure that
there are i'm sure there are people that
have worked with me that don't like me
it happens everyone has but sometimes
people don't like someone for something
that's not the person's fault that's
true so and and i'll be the one to say
that so
if if you can sense someone is trying to
whatever they want to be the director
and they are kind of like coming from
the side
and doing things what's the best way to
defuse some of that
without having to call a department head
and send them home are there ways
of course uh maybe not humor to get them
right well i try to figure out what
again makes that person tick and
sometimes
it's just identifying little things like
they need this thing in craft
services right it's sometimes figuring
out
uh that they love this type of coffee
and having a pa go get it for them
whatever it may be it's sometimes just
little things it's observations right so
even a little observation like that can
go a long way to make
someone feel wanted and needed on a set
because i think that when people want to
take charge it's not usually
because they're a dominating bully on
the set it can be
usually it's because they think you're
not competent i think that usually
that's the reason that people try to do
that and so if you display competency
if you're calm if you know what you want
to do
i am this may be shocking to you but i'm
usually not hot-headed
and so i i keep a very even
tone even with myself even if i'm not in
a good mood or if i'm tired or whatever
it is i try not to project that onto the
set
because i know that will then trickle
down
so i try to find the things that that
person needs to feel comfortable on set
even if it's a creature comfort like
a coffee or a crafty thing but then it's
also just
making sure that they understand that i
understand what i'm doing
i've been very lucky that i haven't had
that happen recently but earlier in my
career for sure
i definitely had to deal with that uh
with actors and
and people working on the film for sure
and i've learned from those lessons and
know
that i have to make sure my shit's
together
before i can tell all these people what
to do
and how to do what's the hardest thing
to film in terms of logistics
the hardest thing to film logistically
is any time you are taking a
crew from one place to another place
on a plane and you're figuring out
all the equipment that needs to come
with you that has to be shipped
that has to be flown and where that's
going to end up
and who on local crew is going to
receive it
where it's going to be and how you're
meshing that stuff with stuff from local
houses
i've dealt this um multiple films
i did it why i did my film in india i
did it
from the film i just did in oklahoma and
i will do it again this summer in the
film and israel
uh that is a lot of logistics
uh i find that if you do your planning
right
you know your schedule comes into place
your team comes into place that's all
fine
but the logistics of getting things from
one place to another
and then dealing with what happens if
something goes wrong
from something that say i have an
oklahoma that has to go back to los
angeles
then you have to deal with that for
example
when we were shooting uh lucia lucasfilm
in april of this year we
had a ready rig that was broken
in flight from los angeles to oklahoma
and the local house in oklahoma city
that's an hour and a half away did not
have it so we had to ship it back to la
and then they had to
ship us back another piece to make sure
we could do
steadicam work on the film now that
doesn't sound like it's a big deal and
at the end of the day it's really not
but i have to then deal with what
happens now that that piece of equipment
is missing for these two days
how do we shoot this scene in a
documentary that i will never have the
opportunity to shoot again
and still get what i plan to do when me
and the dp were shot listing
uh and so there are plenty of examples
of things like that that happen
even when i was shooting desires of the
heart in india the equipment came from
mumbai
to buccaneer on a train a three-day
train ride
across india we were lucky that nothing
broke
but if something had broken i'm not
exactly sure what we would have done
in the desert next to the pakistan
border
i don't know what we would have done and
so depending on where you're shooting
like in oklahoma i can have something
swapped out but if i'm in india
on the desert you might be out of
luck so you got to figure out
how to adjust your plans to make sure
everything keeps moving should a good
film leave
unanswered questions oh i think so i i
don't think a film has to answer every
single question
uh in our previous interview i believe
we talked about this in fact
i think that every film is a kind of a
question mark if you if you do it right
and i still believe that i
i think that most good films leave you
something to think about
i'm not saying that means you need to be
sloppy or lazy or not have a good plot
or
you know direct and do your job properly
but you need to i think to make a great
film
to leave something that has the audience
left to wonder
to ask a question about uh when we did
angel of anywhere
i specifically when where i was working
with the
writers on the script when we came up
with the concept
that i wanted it to have an intentional
vagueness to its ending that left the
audience with a question
instead of a period i think
in my own personal tastes that is what
makes a better film because then i don't
walk out and say oh
everything was resolved that was lovely
it gives me something to think about
long after i've watched it and the films
that i've most enjoyed
do that and so i try to emulate that in
my own work
any recent films that have left with any
recent films that left me with a
question
mark a star was born was an interesting
film i thought that left some very
interesting questions now i did not love
the film
yeah i liked half of the film i thought
it was half of a good film i thought the
other half of it was
um i thought the second half of the star
was born the script wasn't very well
constructed
but i thought that it did leave some
interesting
character stuff with you in fact i think
the character stuff in that film is far
more interesting than the plot itself
because bradley cooper and lady gaga
gave
and sam elliott for that matter all game
right terrific career defining
performances
in my opinion which is a weird thing to
say that i didn't love the film
but i loved the characters inside of it
because the way that they constructed
character
and remarkably for a first-time director
bradley cooper is amazing
amazing i can't wait to see what he does
again truly
those characters left me with questions
because they're all ambiguous
there's nothing about those characters
that are defined
in in this kind of specific way
it is always asking you a question about
who they are what their motivations are
what their purposes
are the three principles not some of the
secondary ones
but lady gaga bradley cooper and sam
elliott
always leave you with something to ask a
question about
about where they come from what their
motivation is there's a
a certain um dynamic about what it means
to be an artist and that i think that's
very honest
and those characters leave you with that
question
and so sometimes it doesn't even have to
be plot because
i think the plot itself isn't very good
but the characters
are fantastic andrew dice clay too it
was great when she came back fabulous
and that was kind of her little
you know well i guess working-class
world that she lived in and and
sort of the safety of her dad and all
these guys you know exactly
it's this world that you know they
create and look i don't like to bat
mouth people's films i'm really not
trying to because i know how hard it is
is to make a film but i think that even
if it's a film that i didn't like in its
totality like a star was born
i understand how well directed that film
was
watching it i also understand how well
acted it was
and so i think that with many films even
the ones that you don't
necessarily like in their entirety that
doesn't make it a good or bad
film i think that's the rotten
tomatozation of how we look at films
right it's 70 percent good or 30
bad it's false that's a um
and that's not even how that thing works
it's an aggregate percentage of
of positive or negative reviews it means
nothing about it's 70
good or bad um i think there are things
that we pull from all films uh
even ones that we like in some ways and
not in others so
it's a good example of that i think did
you see eighth grade speaking i loved it
i loved it too you know someone got out
of the left they were just i won't say
which scene it was
it wasn't the uh totally pc scene and
they had just had it and they
made this big production i thought it
was a wonderful film
eighth grade was also what now eighth
grade i think had one of the best
screenplays of the year that was such a
sharply written script and elsie fisher
is a revelation i mean it really was a
wonderful wonderful film
yeah what are your five best filmmaking
roles
oh yes this is one youtube love last
time uh let me think
[Music]
maybe they've changed they might have
changed a little bit so last time we
spoke i know i gave you five filmmaking
rules and i really enjoyed reading your
comments on that
uh the things i think that have have
changed
and evolved for me in some ways have a
lot to do with preparation process more
than being on set
uh i think for me the first question is
is this a plot that i respond to uh
and in that plot is there a theme that i
think i can weave
in that's going to help that plot out
if i can answer yes to that then i will
do
the film or think about it with them
right so then the second question
becomes
what's the budget for this film is this
realistic
is this a budget that we can execute
does it make sense that i
say yes to it um if the answer is i love
this script i love this story i love
this documentary concept whatever it is
but i know that i can't film it on the
resources they have available
i will ask if they have the opportunity
to
have this much more before we start
filming
before i say yes or no they come back
with yes
and it ends up working i'll do it if
they say no i'll walk away
because at this point in my career i'm
not going to
choose to do something that i know i
can't pull off because that's not good
for me
the third thing i want to know is
what kind of autonomy do i have or don't
have
on working on a film because even though
you're directing a film that doesn't
mean
that you have especially at this point
in your career full autonomy on the
creative product do you have final cut
are you sharing final cut do you have
you know a producer that wants to run
off with it and do their own thing
these are all questions i want to know
the answer to and will be in my legal
work before i
sign to say yes to do anything because
if it's something where the producers
want me to come in
direct the film and leave i'm not going
to do it i want to be there from start
to finish because at the end of the day
my name will be on there as director and
if i did not truly direct
the totality of the film then
i'm not doing it because there are three
films you make
the one that you conceptualize the one
you shoot
and the one you edit and if i'm not part
of all three of those films it's not
mine
i'll say no if that happens so the
fourth
piece of that is when i've said yes to
something
it's about making sure that the right
people are in the right positions
uh that i have the right dp the right
editor production designer costume
designer et cetera goes
goes down the line i want to make sure
that i have
a mixture of people that i've worked
with before that i
need our working relationship with and
specific roles dependent on the content
and i also need to bring in new blood to
bring in fresh ideas
in other ways so for example i think a
good place you sometimes do that as in
production design
my dp and i have worked together for
years and so we have this shorthand
that's very beneficial but a different
production designer odd film might give
a different look to a film that you
might need a specific film right
and so it's really about identifying who
are my trusted collaborators that i
always am bringing back for specific
things and what's different about the
specific
project that i need new ideas for
because if i'm hiring these people to do
their jobs it's about me
communicating the overarching theme and
the vision i have for the film
but then it's making sure that i've
empowered them to do that job
and not micromanage them and say oh well
this is how this this and this should be
i've hired a professional for a reason
and so it's
then my job to find the right
professional
final thing is that before we've
ever started filming um i want to make
sure that
all of my ducks are in a row i want to
make sure all the legal work is done
with our our actors if we're dealing
with sag
making sure escrow is clear this is not
glamorous stuff by the way that has
nothing to do with me as a director this
is more producer stuff right
but i think as a director it's important
for me to be cognizant
of it i need to know for example how
many
hours have these actors or union crew
whatever it is
how much are they working what is their
day are they working an
eight-hour day or a 12-hour day because
when i choose to go
over if i choose to go over if i choose
to call
grace whatever it is what are the
repercussions
of the decisions that i make
because the second that i call
overtime i have now triggered all these
new rules for
multiple unions that my producers and
financiers now have to deal with because
i made that choice
if i am not cognizant of
what those parameters are if i don't
have a schedule
that can fit within what those
parameters are
i need to adjust it because i have to be
respectful to
all of those entities involved i need to
ensure that my crew has rest
my cast has rest i need to make sure
that the budget
that i agreed to on step two
i can actually execute because if i go
over time
i've then cut into the wiggle room that
i might have had
otherwise so that's how i try to think
about it now
we talked earlier about this middle area
and and we've talked about
some of the comments and yeah there's
different reasons why people leave
different comments
and most of it has to do with them yeah
i'm fine and and
but let me just play the devil's
advocate here because i could say oh
this guy is good looking he's young
like but do you do you want to share how
much time maybe that you've taken from
your own personal life
to do all this and to not have a
personal life and not be able to
do some of the fun things like hang out
or whatever yes
film festivals are great but in the
sense that it's work it's work
i think that people forget sometimes i'm
partially kidding about youtube comments
i love you all but
the um you know everybody has a
different way of doing something and
that's okay
um but everyone that works in film
we all have to spend a lot of time away
from our significant others
from our from our friends for our family
to to really
do the things that we want to do
it's it's in some ways the first
priority in your life um and that's not
to discount
your you know your relationships and
such but
when you work for someone if you have a
regular job right like i go to work at a
cpa office every day
you have someone that has created the
safety net for you you're going to get
this much money every month you're gonna
have a health insurance plan you're
gonna have all these things
when you're in film unless you have
gotten to a point where you've joined
the dga
or the actors guild whatever it is you
are your safety net you are your own
brand and that means that you
have to provide for all of those things
that someone else
might help provide for you and so
it is a sacrifice that you have to
figure out to say what is the balance
between my professional life and my
personal life
past few months in particular have been
rough because i've been traveling all
over the place and on very tight
deadlines
i know my husband would like to see more
of me but he doesn't
so i mean that is what it is but he
understands and he knows that he knows
that
i have to do these things to
get from point a to point b and he can
see the trajectory of of where i have
evolved over the years so i think that
you know as long as you're submitting
another or your family or friends
whatever
understands that and and can see
progress
you know they can put up with that
because they know where you're going
uh but you do have to deal with a great
bit of that
sacrifice and time commitment um because
if you're not
invested you're not gonna get there
you just won't you you won't see that
evolution
from point a to point b because you're
not putting in the time or the effort to
get there
james what would you say to that person
that just can't get that first project
off the ground
well no one's asking for your film let's
start there
no one cares about you no one wants to
hear your film no one wants to hear your
story because they don't know you exist
uh i don't mean that in a harsh way but
they don't
get care about your film and so if you
want your first film to be made unless
you're independently wealthy which i
was not independently wealthy being the
child of teachers
i had to figure out how to do it i had
to figure out how to put money together
my first film was a short film called
the car wash with a dear friend of mine
named edith ivey who is still with us
she's almost 91 now
and she agreed to be in my film because
she liked my script
and i
figured out how to finance it by making
high school graduation dvds with a
camcorder
having a basic package for twenty
dollars
where you would get just your college
graduation on a dvd
but for thirty dollars you could get an
upgraded package with an exclusive
behind the scenes photo gallery before
graduation and your name printed on a
disk
eighty percent of the people bought the
deluxe edition even though there's not
really a big difference between the two
but then i was able to use that money
to channel into making my first film i
was able to fly edith
to states of savannah to statesboro
i was able to pay for a hotel do
catering all of these things i was still
in college
um and i didn't have money but i
made enough money to pay her sag student
fee
i made enough money to do all those
other things
and it was because i
looked at things entrepreneurially and i
said how can i do this one thing
to do this other thing because nobody
cared about my film nobody cared about
me it's like oh you're not
you know i've never made anything who
cares you're in college whatever
i made it happen for myself and because
i made that choice and because i
cast the right actor because i took it
to film festivals because i went to
those film festivals
all on my own dime not because i'm
independently wealthy again
i was able to get to a point where now
people
give me checks to make films
and it was because i took that
initiative so it's not
it's not that you can't make your film
but you're choosing not to make it
because you're choosing not
to take that leap there is no guarantee
when you take that leap that you will
have that wonderful series of events
happen
none i was just lucky that
people liked the film that i made and so
the best thing you can do
is write the best damn script you can
make get the best feedback you can from
people you know
from people that happen to work in the
industry if there's an online script
service that can review your script
whatever it is
take the notes take the feedback
don't reject it embrace those things
because you probably don't know what
you're doing yet because you haven't
done it
and then make it the best film you can
make and then take it to festivals put
it on the internet do whatever you have
to do
and then do it again and it's gonna
still take you a while
before people give you a check to make a
film unless you suddenly get you know 20
million hits on your
on your film on youtube or if it wins
the jury prize at sundance right
it's very unlikely that you're suddenly
going to start getting checks and so you
have to
keep doing what i did which is do
something else
use that money to make something and
over time
i started shifting from having to spend
my own money to spending other people's
but with that
comes entirely different sub challenges
entirely
but you keep saying lucky can i just
interject all you also sound very
organized and very disciplined
well you have to be a and and that's but
that's not a skill that you're born with
i don't think
that's a skill that you learn but i mean
i do sincerely believe that there is an
element of luck i know you're probably
tired of me hearing that word but
there is an element of luck but of
course there also is and that is the
first thing
preparation discipline and hopefully
some talent too
because you've got to figure out how to
get to that point where you want to be
and if you are not prepared
organized ready when the day comes
you're making two
features at the same time you're not
going to be ready to do it
because you don't know how to get there
you don't know how to structure and
discipline and deliver because
it's very different when you go from a
point where well this is a thousand
dollars i raised of my money to make it
a little short
too i'm now spending hundreds of
thousands of dollars or millions of
dollars
of someone else's money that has to be
made back
because it's a business it's not
personal anymore that's that transition
and so if you can't make that transition
of discipline
no one else will ever give you another
multi-million dollar check
to make a film ever again in your life
won't happen
do you think a lot of indie filmmakers
lack patience and they want to go from
making a little short film to
avengers i think that sometimes
there are stories of filmmakers and
directors
that and writers who just seemingly come
out of nowhere and suddenly they are the
world's big hit
and i think a lot of us myself included
uh
will sometimes look at those people and
go like how did they what did they
you know but you don't know the
circumstances in which
that person arrived they might have been
working for 10 years
doing little things and now suddenly
this is their big moment right
they might have had an uncle who is a
studio head or an aunt or someone like
there are a lot of
scenarios and so i think that we
sometimes look at those things and try
to project
as is human nature that thing on
ourselves we're like
that should be me like i'm so much more
talented than that person
but the way they got there is not the
way you got there those are two
different things my journey is so much
different than
anybody else's and so is anybody else's
from mine
the thing about interviews like this or
anything that's about filmmaking
is it is subjective based on my
experience
that does not mean it is the ultimate
gospel on film
it's my experience sure yours might be
different
and that's totally fine so the reason we
get impatient is because we're
projecting what we
think we should be ours based on the
experiences
that are not ours so it's impossible i
think
for you to get anywhere if you're
focused on
x person is where i should be it's a
waste of your time
be focused on what you do because your
voice
is different than my voice which is
different than anyone else's
we all if we've been working long enough
have figured out what we want to
say and what you say will always be
different
than what x person is doing because it's
yours
so do that don't do them they've done
themselves
it's time for you to you any advice on
developing a character
to me developing a character is
a very collaborative process so you know
if it's a script that you
wrote or if it's a script that was
written for you or you
purchased or whatever it is um you know
there are other entities
involved uh it's not just about i'm the
director and here's the character it's
about saying here's what this the writer
wrote
uh if i did not write the script and
this is what the writer's intention
is for that character within the arc of
the story
once i get involved i usually have some
notes there's only one or two scripts i
think i've ever read that
i would say leave it as is there's only
one that i'm developing right now
that i would i thought was perfect
um doesn't happen very often when you
realize scripts
but if you have those notes it's then
working with the writer to see how you
want to steer
the story and for me with theme being a
huge thing it's about thinking about
characters within the context of theme
so now the writer and i have you know
come to something that we're satisfied
with
it's not my job to be a dictator to the
screenwriter they're creative as well
so it's really about again meshing
sensibilities making sure that if the
screenplay is
is one thing i want to be something
slightly different conveying that to the
writer in a way that's respectful of
their work
but also finding something that you all
agree on because i don't think it's good
if you have a situation where
the writer and the director both hate
the thing they're working on right you
want to keep everybody happy
as long as it's within the totality of
what the vision should be
but that's one of the things you should
decide before you say yes to a project
and then you're done with your your
notes right you've figured out what you
want to modify
uh then you're presenting it to actors
who are going to have their own take
entirely
and so if i'm going to start developing
a character
with the actor it's now a new entity and
its own
right this character that i have
developed thematically on page
with the writer is not necessarily going
to be the same one
that is portrayed on film with the actor
because they're going to bring their own
experiences and ideas
about what it means to perform that
character
their motivations their tics their their
insecurities their confidences they
bring that to the character and
sometimes
that's different than what you intended
i find usually it's better
you just have to make sure as a director
that
whatever that character becomes with the
actor and in collaboration
with the actor is still
in the intent of what you wrote
and within the general character arc of
the story how that affects
other characters when those choices are
made and how those
as an ensemble create
the entire theme that i want to deliver
in the film
that being said you think it's easier to
work on your own or to have quote
collaborators i think that it's always
easier to work on your own but it's
never better
i think that you know i'm so skeptical
of anybody who says they're a writer
director actor producer editor
they're not good at all those jobs
there's one or two they're good at
and i think that when people say they
are multi-hyphenates of all those things
they usually are not good at any of them
be one or two things and be good at them
that will make
your work better and so i can live in
isolation
and and technically could i direct edit
produce
shoot technically i could i
i know how to do all of those things but
i know what i'm best at uh
i'm a good director i'm a good editor
and so i will sometimes do those two
things
and even while i'm editing work i've
directed if i think that i'm not being
disciplined enough
or if i'm not being
judicious or i'm lost in the woods i
always bring in a second editor
because i can't be precious about it in
my own work because that looks poorly on
me as a director right
so you have to be cognizant of those
things
so could you work on your own and do
your own thing sure you can
but your work's going to suffer i think
most people that do that their work does
suffer
there are very few examples of people
that are successful that
i don't think uh most people can pull
that off
but in the middle let's say i mean
starting out maybe they
they can't afford yeah oh yeah when
you're starting out you have to right
that's
now that's different right like if
you're starting out sure
like when i first started out i yes i
was producer director editor all of
those things
but if you want to make that transition
to the middle the middle best place uh
you can't uh you can't do that anymore
you you have to set that aside and you
have to start
leaning in on and working with people
who are professionals in
those areas i don't think you would go
to
using the account example a cpa who is
also a chef who is also
an uber driver you would probably think
that one of those things they may not be
very good at
uh it's the same thing in film and maybe
the need to
hire out it means that you are entering
the middle right well it also i think
shows that you're entering a different
mindset right because
there are two kinds of filmmakers i i
think there's the professional filmmaker
which
i'm lucky to be now and then there's the
ones that do it for themselves who just
kind of make it and they have their
regular job and
and that's what they do and that's
totally fine neither one of those
are bad or wrong but if you're going to
be a
film professional you've got to work
with other people because
they are trained specifically in
specialty areas that you are not
and if i'm trying to do all of those
things
i'm invariably going to drop one of
those balls or not do one of those
things well
because i am not trained
i am not a lawyer who
took the bar and passed it
i am not going to write my own contract
because i
took an entertainment law class in
college that does not make me a lawyer
that means i might understand basic
verbologies and structures
but i'm not going to have myself write
my own contract with a company to direct
a film
because i know that that doesn't make me
good at it that means i
know something about it i will hire the
lawyer
that's been trained in entertainment law
that passed the bar
that is practicing in multiple states to
do my negotiations
for me it's the same thing with hiring a
crew
would you hire a lawyer do you want to
do your own legal i don't think so
i don't want to do that i'm not trained
in it i'll screw me over in the end
same thing will happen if you try to do
everything yourself
we asked you this question before but
i'm really great at repeating myself so
i'm going to ask it again
i'm told yes so there's this quote at
the end of your demo reel
and it says and i quote as a filmmaker
you have this opportunity to make
projects of quality different films that
mean something
that's what i look for was something
and that's actually it's an old demo
reel of mine i totally had forgotten
about that
and those one i had i think five or six
years ago i don't think my current one
has it on it and i just launched a new
website so i should know the answer to
this
but no i don't think that's on there but
the quote is still true
um i did an interview with a magazine a
few years ago and that was a quote that
i gave
them and i
what i mean by that projects that mean
something is as vague as that
sounds to me it has deep purpose i'm
really interested
in making films that say something about
the human condition
i'm very interested in exploring
people and and ideas and
and exploring really what make people
tick
uh it's the dramatic core of who we are
is as humans
for me every film i make i try
to find in that core
what i'm trying to express about
human identity about
human loss human processes
to give the audience that question mark
when they
are done watching the film
to observe something hopefully about
themselves
um i'm i'm sure that must sound like a
massive ego thing when i
say that out loud it's not that i
know the answers to all of life's ills
i'm 31
still learning but i am
interested in using film as a medium
to provoke a response from an audience
to think about
themselves in a different way or to see
the world in a different way
or to think about themselves in a
different way
i think for me so much of that is
informed by growing up in town 123
people living in los angeles
working around the world that i think
often a friends or family members
different people that have not had
those opportunities to see things in a
different way i think when we
live our lives in one place and that's
all we do or if we don't travel much
you know our world is this box and
i've been lucky enough to go outside of
that box
and i want to bring some of those
experiences from my own perspective
back into the films that i make
now you may not agree with that
perspective whatever it may be
but that is my voice that is what i
gather
from the totality of those experiences
and it's how i express myself on film
i always want the audience to walk away
with a new idea or a thought process
that makes them
think because i feel like if i haven't
done that then i haven't done my job as
a director and that's what something
means to me
he did a film recently right that is
about uh sort of like white privilege
versus a person of color and what
they're doing
every nine hours yeah we talk about that
i'm all part of the trailer first
i produced a film called every nine
hours with novelist jim st
jermaine he wrote a book called a stone
of hope
uh he was on president obama's council
for social justice
uh he grew up in haiti and then
immigrated to brooklyn to find out he
was just as poor there as he was
back home and he wrote a memoir about
these experiences
a stone of hope which you can you can
buy anywhere books everywhere
a wonderful book and i met him on a
trip ironically to tulsa oklahoma two
years ago
uh that the billionaire george kaiser
financed
50 of us from all over the country to
come see the future of tulsa
in fact that was the reason i got
thought about for this documentary
because i had been
on that trip and jim and i met each
other on that trip
and he had just published the book and
we stayed in touch and he reached out to
me last year and said you know i
wrote this short uh about uh
race relations america and i
really want you to produce it for me and
and uh
and so i did and it was a really really
great experience
he wanted the experience of making a
short film before he makes a
book adaptation of a stone of hope which
they're kind of preparing to make into a
film
so he just wanted to go through that
process and use his voice and his
experiences to say something about race
relations
uh from his perspective of being a black
man from being an immigrant
and really express what was on his mind
and he is
uh you know he's very very eloquent he
and jesse eisenberg have been doing this
tour across the country talking about
race relations and
uh it's just remarkable and so we did
the film we had danny trejo in it some
other
folks uh it was a wonderful shoot we did
it here in los angeles in culver city
and uh that will come out next month i'm
very excited to share it with you guys
can you give us any uh talking points
about the film yeah it's uh
so jim co-directed it with adam margolis
who is
emmy award-winning uh director of
television
and uh they co-directed together and we
shot it in three locations in los
angeles it's a very simple film it's
essentially
one big dialogue about what happens to a
man of mixed race when the police pulls
him over for nothing specific
which i know to be true from many
friends of mine of color that that is
something that does happen in america
whether or not we like to admit it or
not
and so it's about the repercussions of
him explaining what happened to his
white girlfriend
it was a really great script and we had
wonderful performers at fantastic
creative
team to do it with and i
it yet again expresses some of what i
want to continue to do
in my own career even though i am not a
black man
i am not a mixed race that's my
experience
i have had that does not mean that
does not exist because i have friends
that have had the same experience
and so if i can use the skill sets that
i've developed and if i can listen to
the stories
that others have to say and be helpful
in some way
and telling that story i want to be
involved in that
and this is something i told jim early
on that i
should not direct it's not something i
should direct because it is not an
experience that i
feel qualified to talk about but
something you should do
because you have a voice and you may not
have done film before but i'll come
produce it
and i'll help guide you through the film
part
and the creative part so you can work
with your experiences
to tell the story that you know how to
tell
you may not have ever directed something
to know how to tell that story
you may need to learn some things but
you know how to tell that story and how
to communicate what you want to
communicate
and so it was really an honor for me to
be involved in that capacity i'm really
proud of how it came out so
check it out soon best advice anyone
ever gave you on
managing a film crew the best advice
i think that anyone ever gave me
and this is true that you
fake it until you make it if you don't
know something on a set
you have to understand
who you can talk to about it and who you
cannot talk to
about it again this is part of being a
director it's about reading
personalities and ideas but that also
applies to the work
that you do now
luckily in the middle where i am now
um i've had enough experiences where
that doesn't happen very often but early
on
early on um when i'm a 19 year old
director ex
you know working with experienced actors
crew and such
you have to project a little bit because
all these people know more than you do
i'm not suggesting you don't ask for
help there's a few very very different
things right in fact people i think
respect you more
when you tell them you don't know
something
versus pretending that you do right
because then they know you have a
certain level of humility to say that
yeah i need help with this thing
what i'm saying is that you need to
understand
who you can do that with and who you
cannot do that with
because there are sometimes people
especially starting out
that can be very toxic or damaging to
you because of their own
egos or or issues that they have
you have to be a good enough read of
people
to understand that i can talk to this
person about this thing that i don't
know
versus that other person who's going to
start gossiping and saying this guy's an
idiot or whoever it is
that's what you got to deal with and
learn and so you fake it in front of the
people that you don't trust
and you ask the people that you do
and if you can't devour you got to
develop that level of discernment
um and it's a skill that will honestly
serve you well
moving forward because you'll do pitch
meetings you'll do money meetings you'll
do actor meetings
and and for me i'm very lucky to be
particular
about the choices that i make now
and when i say yes to things it's
because i've read
all of those entities it's because i've
said i like this financier i don't think
they're a crook i like this producer
we're going to mesh well together we
have similar creative alignments
i want to cast this actor not just
because they're talented
but because i know that we can work
together i'm not going to cast an
even if the world's most
talented actor
because it's gonna be a waste of my time
and energy i got too many other things
to deal with
i don't have time to deal with that so
figure out personalities and then fake
it until you make it
tip-offs to personalities how do you
know when you're
somewhere the tension's high you know
because of time money
that this is a person that i can
actually ask a question to who's not
gonna
i think it's it's it sounds so ethereal
but i think it has a lot to do with
demeanor
and body language um i think but i think
that that's
maybe something that i
am better at most of the time i
sometimes get it wrong but
most of the time uh because
i specialize in that for a living right
directing's about
about if you're a dramatic director not
like an action director right it's it's
more about language and motion and and
expression not about like here's the
scene in the shot it's it's a different
kind of way of thinking about
interpersonal relationships
and so i think that if you are more
attuned to that if you're more of a
dramatic
person then i think it makes
it becomes easier to read that tone
in what people say because what people
say and what people say are two
very very different things and so if
those two are not congruent
usually that tells me a lot about a
person if i can trust them or not
yep i've learned that the hard way too
yeah it's like
the there are people that um what was it
maya angelos
maya angelou said that when people show
you who they are the first time believe
them that's true
it's one of the wisest pieces of writing
i've ever read in my life
because if someone is what you see here
and they're still that person when
they're angry when they're mad whatever
it is
you can trust them if it's somebody
whose body language says this then their
mouth says this
you usually are a snake and you should
chop it off at the head
immediately yeah that's how you that's
how you get through that and so i
learned that lesson
and that's how i try to discern